I told you we check in with the Colts
the Colts beat rider for the
Indianapolis Stars Stephen holder who
joins us Stephen good morning thanks for
joining us what did you expect
last night I expected a rusty Andrew
Luck I expected some nerves I expected
maybe you know some some quick throws to
get him in rhythm and I think Frank
Reich ensured that all of those things
happen and yes Andrew Luck was no
probably not in midseason form but
probably about what I expected from him
I think this is more about the actual
event and the actual finality of finally
getting out there than anything specific
between the lines what did you see cuz I
I want to know how good that offensive
line is because we've seen how bad that
offensive line can be so what did you
see from that offensive line or have you
seen from that offensive line that would
probably give me a little bit more
confidence that my quarterback can last
a full season I saw a lot to like last
night and look the situation that tackle
is not perfect right now Anthony
Costanza I think surface often sublime
unless tackle he's out right now he'll
be back for the regular season so the
tackle situation is a little tenuous but
let me tell you something that front
line the middle of the offensive line
was so stable and Quinton Nelson is so
big in the interim and intimidating
Andrew Luck was able to step up into the
pocket and that's not something he's
been able to do the middle of that
offensive line for years has been a
problem and the pressure has come right
up the gut it's been right in his face
so when a quarterback can't confidently
step up into the pocket when the
pressure comes then he's got a problem
interlock was able to do that
comfortably last night and that was a
beautiful thing that's not something
we've seen from the Colts yeah I
remember leading up to the draft a scout
said you know Quinton Nelson doesn't
play the right position to be drafted
number one overall but he thought he was
the best player in the draft what have
you seen I was just told you know what
he's a tenure guy plug and play nasty
guy and is gonna be great
well it was I mean the Colts response to
that because they've heard that
criticism too and they have a think of
very fair response to that which is look
guards are getting paid astronomically
nowadays and if you look around the
league it's really true I think there
have been less there has been less
distinction between guards and offensive
tackles these days look I think
obviously oftens tackle they're always
gonna be held in a little bit higher
regard I think but the guards in today's
NFL they matter and including those of
the guy who's going to let you run the
ball more effectively - by the way which
I thought they did at times last night
that's been a problem for the Colts and
and obviously keeps your quarterback
clean so look at the defensive tackles
who are playing in the league today and
that kind of correlates to why the
guards are so important so Clinton
Nelson I mean he is he is the biggest
plug-and-play guards we've seen in years
and the Colts feel fortunate to have
them are the Colts a playoff contender I
don't know yet they are really really
young and defensively they're gonna take
some lumps I think and he saw Russell
Wilson gave them fits on that first
drive last night I think the defense is
going to be a work in progress it's a
new scheme it's very different they
don't have all the personnel yet so I
don't I don't know that I go that far
yet but here's what I tell you is that
Andrew Luck if you watch him last night
he's rusty and he's got a ways to go but
I think this is gonna be a situation in
2018 where Andrew Luck gets
progressively better as the season
progresses and if that happens then who
knows look I think it's a lot I don't
like it accused of being a homer when I
say it is luck it's been a I think
awfully underrated quarterback this guy
the team's he has played with in the
past where their rosters were
embarrassing utterly embarrassing in
some cases and he won eleven in five he
went 11 and 5 3 is in Rowland once the
AFC Championship game in his third
season that's the last evening's luck
was healthy we have somebody on staff
Paulie my producer who does an Andrew
Luck impersonation I'd be curious what
do you think
Paulie would you like to die was a good
night it wasn't it wasn't book club good
but it was a good night got the ball
flying around out there as the kids say
back to you Dan
alright what do you think Stephen you
know what
pretty accurate except not lately
I see the different Angela the guys
totally different that was Angela I
exist radians like press conferences
okay for like five years and now I'm
getting an to luck cutting a vein okay
kidding amp you look horrible and he's
reluctant to play again I don't know who
this guy is
I really don't I'm just telling you
Andrew Luck press conferences used to be
sleep-inducing and now I feel like I'm
getting I am getting more honesty and
more vulnerability last night you know
he said he didn't know last night
whatever happened he actually said that
you know I really doubt it at times at
this whatever come so I thought he has
changed this experience has been
something else
so yes accurate except lately Paulie can
you act like you're you're cutting a
vein here ah you know I've grown a lot
as a human not the college boy at the
Stanford Cardinal anymore ha Holder good
job over there at the the star read it
every day more the business section he
actually did say that he supposedly
subscribes to the actual newspaper
because you know you can't read a
newspaper on flip phone right so he
subscribes to the actual newspaper I
mean listen I don't even use it okay and
I work there right are you know about it
a myspace page and really an iPad so
I've never actually seen the preparing
he has an iPad so I think he actually
does embrace some level of technology
allegedly hey Steven thanks for joining
us safe travels back we appreciate your
time all right thanks that's a Stephen
holder the Colts beat writer for the
Indianapolis Star joining us from
Seattle for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]